BACK AND ENJOY THIS ONE OFF THE.
TURNED OUT ANDNDS PULLING IT TO.
GOES BACKND SHOT
BLOCKED IN FRONT BY LARSON.
IT B.
A FIRST ROUND PICK OF FRANCIS I.
THE  SHOVE.
DILIGENT AND B MARKED BY
SLAVIN, EBERLE TO THE BACKIOD .
LATE PASS, GIORDANO THROUGH THE.
SMITH, TOOK A GREAT PASS FROM
TONYONT.
AND BRENDAN SMITH'S SHOT IS ABLE
TO FIND THE SCORERS.
KRAKEN KICK OFF THE RLL.
GIORDANO, FUMBLES IT, JORDAN
T
POST.
IT'S
KOTKANIEMI FOR CAROLINA.
NOW,
IT'S A TIP TUCK FROM THE SLOT.
CHANAN CAR
ANDERSON ON THE TEE, AND BRANSON
SMITH.
A TURNOVER AT A
GROUP THAT INCLUDES TROCHECK,
SVECHNIKOV IN A GRADE-A SIDE
OF THE GOAL, TROCHECK, A POWER .
OF FRIENDS, HE TAKES IT DEEP.
SHADOWED AND DEFENDED
PERIOD.
LAST ONE ON AHO
JOHANSSON, ALL THE WAY AROUND,P
HOLDING.H THE CENTER ZONE, MOVES
OFF THE STICK, RIGHT IN FRONT.
MOVES ALONG FOR LAUZON.
TROUBLE BREWING HERE. SAVE THER.
YOU WILL HAVE TO MARK IT DOWN.
>> I DID,PERIOD.
OH, LARSSON.
STRETCHING OUT FULLY ON SCORESH
FOR
HEY!
WHAT ON
THE PLAY.
AND THAT